USDA operates full-time to punish and
destroy the small farmer in this country
and to promote the mertile interest we
came across an email exchange between
the executive officers of Monsanto
corporation with the head of the
pesticide division his he was really
secretly working for Monsanto and they
were telling him in these emails you
have to kill this study was a study that
would have examined the length between
exposure to Roundup the biggest
herbicide in the world and non- hutkin
and foma Americans can see the
corruption and we all have this feeling
that this system has been rigged against
the American middle class they're strip
mining the wealth from the American
people and and destroying the health of
our children and causing this chronic
disease epidemic that is the biggest
Bight on the American middle class in
our country and that it's it's being
used to
benefit this oligarchy this no corporate
kleptocracy if you've been following me
a while you know that I've been drinking
ag1 all year no matter where I go or
what I do if I'm at the racetrack if I'm
in Europe for six weeks no matter what
I'm drinking ag1 every single morning
when I started drinking ag1 daily what I
noticed was that my gut health improved
I could eat so many different foods
without it bothering me my skin has
gotten better my hair is healthier so
many function
that everybody wants to get better got
better it's so awesome and I've been
bragging about it so much that my
friends and my family have also started
taking it and they love it as well ag1
is the supplement that I trust to
support my body's daily needs and that's
why we have been partners for so long if
you want to take ownership of your
health it starts with ag1 try ag1 and
get a free one-ear supply of vitamin D3
K2 plus five free AG G1 travel packs
with your first purchase go to drink
a1.com pretty intense that's drink
a1.com pretty intense check it out hello
everybody how are you all
doing did you guys get kept up late with
cars driving
225 or 30 m an hour down on the front
strip at 4:00 a.m. I was still awake for
that who stayed up that late no good cuz
you want to be ready for today uh well
thank you so much for coming it is my
true honor to sit here with Robert of
Kennedy Jr thank you so much should I
call you Bob yeah okay all right well
welcome
Bob you know when I pay attention to the
words spoken in
politics when I listen to him I I just
manage to keep on listening and that
when you speak it really feels like
you're speaking from the heart from EXP
experience from seeing it from living it
and really believing it and I just think
that that's something rare in politics
and I don't know if you all feel the
same but I I believe that deserves a
hand I think the first and most obvious
question is this transition that you've
made recently from the Democratic ticket
to becoming an independent why'd you do
that of all thanks for having me D
thanks for
your your courage not only your your
physical courage and breaking all these
barriers but also the moral courage that
you've uh shown over the past several
years by going against the
orthodoxies um I I did not want to leave
the Democratic party Democratic party
has been my home since uh since I was
born it was my family has been memb the
Democratic party has been an important
uh feature of Our Lives a defining
feature of Our Lives since all of my
great grandparents came over in 1848 and
from the Potato
Famine um from fleeing Ireland but uh
because of famine but also a a very
oppressive government in Ireland that
passed rules starting in 1691 that
forbade Catholics from part
participating in uh in from practicing
law or being part of a profession from
owning
land uh from
voting or from holding political office
and when the Irish arrived in this
country and most of them came over
around that time they took the politics
like a starving person takes the food
and they immediately uh found a place
their place in this country
uh in the political system and my
great-grandfather honey
Fitz uh was the first Irish Catholic
mayor Boston the G first let me put it
this way the ghetto there was an Irish
Catholic before him but he was a he was
kind of a puppet mayor um and he was the
first real Irish Catholic
mayor his contemporary was Patrick
Kennedy who was my
great-grandfather on the other side who
was a Ward Captain he was a saloon own
owner and a w captain in
Boston and his son Joseph Kennedy
married Rose Fitzgerald who was my U my
great-grandfather Anie Fitz's
daughter and uh and they had nine kids
and almost all of them were involved in
politics so my uncle John Kennedy became
resident the eldest brother was killed
in World War II um my my uncle John
Kennedy became the first Irish Catholic
uh president of the United States and I
was in Catholic school at that age 10
years old and politics was almost merged
with religion because it was you know
every Catholic in our country was
supporting my uncle because it was a
civil rights issue for them um my father
was attorney general he was then senator
from New York and he died in uh after
winning the California primary
um my uncle Ted Kennedy was the one of
the oldest serving members of the United
States Senate he was there for over 50
years and uh so I grew up in campaigns
campaigning working and um and feeling
like the Democratic party was my home so
it was almost inconceivable to me that I
would ever leave the Democratic party I
saw the Democratic party straying from
many of the values that my family had
stood for and that were part of what
people called a Roosevelt uh Democrat or
a Kennedy
Democrat and um you know my I felt in
the initial parts of the campaign that
my job was to bring the Democratic party
back to its its natal
values um but there were people around
me like Dennis kenich who was running
the campaign who was saying from the
beginning that the Democratic Party is
out controlled by big corporations by
the military industrial
complex and they would rather have Trump
as president again and you as their
candidate um and that's what they did to
Bernie Sanders that's what they did to
Tulsi gabard um that's what they did to
James Webb that Progressive people who
challenge the this corrupt merger of
state and corporate power that Now
controls both political parties what
they call the UN party that that cabal
would never allow me uh to uh to be the
Democratic nominee my numbers my falling
numbers were very good particularly at
the
outset um but uh and I felt that if I
was able to go through the primaries
that I could
win my numbers also show that our
polling showed that President Biden
probably could not beat president Trump
but that could beat him and all of our
numbers showed me beating president
Trump if IR ran is a Democrat by eight
points beating uh uh Governor dantz by
11 points but that's because the
Democrats who don't like me the people
who watch CNN MSNBC and read the New
York Times And if I if I was living in
that information bubble I would have a
very low opinion of
myself but the people who are kind of
Trapped in that bubble who were very
very hostile to me and see me you know
accept this kind of Orthodoxy that I was
Annie baxer and that I was a conspiracy
theorist and kind of a crazy
person that they if they if I was pit
against President Trump that they would
still vote for me because their loathing
for president Trump is so
ferocious and and so I would get them
but I would also get large numbers of
Republicans and uh I would i' beat
everybody in the independence so the
best strategy for me was to win the
Democratic nomination and then basically
sail into the White House um but the the
uh the party rearranged a lot of the
rules to make it virtually impossible
for me to win I'll just give you one
example there somebody made a list of 60
rule changes that they made to keep me
from getting the nomination but one of
those they made a rule that anybody any
candidate who steps into the state of
New
Hampshire would not be able to get any
of the uh delegates from New Hampshire
so every vote that I won in New
Hampshire would go to President
Biden and um and they they were moving
toward adopting the same rule for Iowa
and the same rule for Georgia the rule
that they propose for Georgia is that if
you stepped into New Hampshire you
couldn't get any delegate from Georgia
they also had a number of other things
they fixed the um the what they call the
plos which are these um uh these
automatic these super
delegates who the party controls and uh
and they would be able to block me my
nomination so it became clear at some
point during the campaign that uh that I
would not be able to run as a Democrat
and and and win and my intention was to
win and and that kind of forced me
everybody else had already in the
campaign had already moved on and I was
the last person to you know finally
realize that I needed to switch parties
well there's a will there's a
way so you spoke about how
corporations take over and control these
parties but there's also rules being put
in place statewise that are changing
things so is it still the corporations
running everything and how does that
happen and how do you get away from them
having the control over these parties
and not being able to
basically see what they're really all
about how do we get away from this
corporate power problem is not even the
control of the parties it's the the
control of the Regulatory Agencies the
phenomena it's called corporate capture
where the regulated industry becomes uh
uh basically gets
ownership and control of the agencies
that are supposed to protect the public
from bad behavior by those
corporations the Regulatory Agencies
become stock puppets for the industries
they're supposed to regulate and I've
watched this phenomena throughout my
career I've sued most of the agencies
I've R many many suits against the
department of agriculture the Department
of Agriculture was created to protect
small family farmers in our country and
to protect the integrity and the
wholesomeness of our food supply but in
reality today in the
USDA it does just the opposite it
represents and promotes the interests of
big factory farms of industrial
agriculture of big companies like
Monsanto and
Carill uh Smithfield foods which is the
biggest pork producer in our country
which is now holy on by the
Chinese um uh Tyson
Purdue and and the big um uh petroleum
fertilizer companies in other words the
oil companies and they really USDA
operates
full-time to punish and destroy the
small farmer in this country and to
promote the Mercantile
interest of these big U industrial
agricultural interest um I I spent a lot
of time suing EPA I've probably brought
more lawsuits against EPA than any other
attorney EPA and I've sued the regulated
Industries as well so the when I sued
Monsanto um we came
across Discovery
documents that showed that it was an
email exchange between the the executive
officers of Monsanto corporation with
the head of the pesticide division EPA
for over a decade a very well-known man
named Jess
Roland and um and it became clear from
these emails that although Jess Roland
was being paid his salary by the
American
taxpayer his he was really secretly
working for Monsanto and they were
telling him in these emails you have to
kill this study you have to falsify this
science you have to uh you have to
publish science by this group of of U of
Mer mercenary uh scientists who were
secretly working for industry we call
them bios stutes um
they in there in one exchange they're
telling Roland you got to kill this
study by atsdr which is a different
agency than EP he had no jurisdiction
over it and he sends them a note back
saying I can't kill that study I have no
jurisdiction over that agency and it was
a study that would have examined the
links between uh exposure to Roundup is
the biggest herbicide in the world and
non hodin
syoma and a bunch of other diseases and
Monsanto desperately needed to kill that
study because it was promoting round up
a
safe and they said you got to kill it we
don't care what it takes and he then
writes a letter back an email back
saying if I I'm gonna do it but if I
succeed in doing it you've got to give
me a gold
medal and the judge in the first two
cases would not the judges we we we went
we went into court with about
2400 Mainly Home
gardeners who had gotten un Hutchin some
f from using Roundup and in the first
case we won uh 289 million from the jury
the second case case we won 89 million
the third
case in the first two cases the judge
would not allow us to show that letter
that email exchange to the jury but in
the third case the judge allowed us to
do it and we asked the jury for a
billion dollars and this is I I'll tell
you the way that this kind of litigation
Works since there's two or three
firms and in each case a different
attorney
does the closing argument and does
different parts of the
litigation the the there was a kid a
35-year-old kid who was a genius who was
going to do the closing argument in that
last case the night before you do the
closing argument you have a debate with
all the attorneys around the table about
what you're going to ask the jury we've
been sitting there watching that jury
for three and a half weeks and trying to
judge what they're going to do and how
much we can ask them for because you
don't want to ask too much you don't
want to overreach because the jury May
punish you for that and give you less
than you ask for so this kid said I'm
gonna ask him for a billion dollars and
we all said no no no you can't do that
and uh that's too much they're going to
punish us if if you do that and but he's
kind of the captain of the ship and he
made an executive decision at that point
this is what I he said I know this jury
is on my side I've been looking him in
the I for three and a half weeks and I
know they're on my side I know I've got
them he asked them for a billion dollars
and they came back with 2.2 billion and
that forced Monsanto finally to come to
the
table but it was because you know
American Americans don't like they they
can see the corruption and we all have
this
feeling that this system has been rigged
against the American middle class that
they're systematically using this
partnership with the government they're
strip mining the wealth from the
American people and and destroying the
health of our
children and causing this chronic
disease epidemic that is the biggest
Bight on the American middle class in
our country people know that they have
even if they don't know the details of
it they have this this feeling that the
whole system is rigged against you know
American citizens and that it's it's
being used to
benefit this oligarchy this new corpor
kleptocracy and um and that was why we
got that response from the jury they
were people they were San Francisco you
know people who just saw that there was
something
wrong and no matter how inculcated they
were into the kind of the Orthodoxy of
the time they were angry about it and so
we see that everywhere I I'm right now
in litigation I'm representing a
thousand families in Colombiana County
Ohio
um who the from East Palestine whose
lives were upended by the norfol
southern spill and it's clear that the
norfol southern spill happened because
of corporate CL capture the railroad
only had one engineer on it it's it's
got you know it's got I don't know like
cars and there's
a uh there there's a a mechanism that's
used in Europe and Australia all over
the world that tells you if a if one of
the wheels in the car is heating up so
we've known about this the agency passed
the regulation saying you've got to
install these but the industry was able
to get a 10-year delay because it would
have caused them you know a small amount
of money but they didn't want to spend
it so we produce during we have produced
now um photographs we know that that
wheel was on fire for 20 miles how do we
know this because of people's doorbell
ringers people have those those videos
on on their front porch and we can watch
this train going by the different houses
with its
wheel at first the wheel is red and it
sparking and then it bursts into flames
and then it starts to burn the whole car
the car was filled with PVC piping and
it was flammable so it was like this
giant Fireball for 20 miles riding a COR
ring across the Ohio country
side and you could see it from the road
but the engineer didn't know it because
he didn't have that sensor the reason he
didn't have that sensor was because of
corporate
capture and as a result that train
derail that has you know now poisoned
everybody in that area people there were
large metanite community that spent a
lot of money it it it takes enormous
amounts of money to transition to
organic farming because it takes years
for the chemicals to uh to get to a
point where you can get that Organic
certification the menites have been
doing that for years and so they had an
advantage on all other organic farmers
in that part of Pennsylvania it produces
a huge amount of really high quality
food well now guess what their Farms are
now covered with dioxin the soils and it
is the most toxic substance that we know
of in the universe that is not
radioactive a single molecule of dioxin
could cause cancer if you ingest it and
um and so and we knew these risks
everybody knew these risks but the
agencies which are supposed to protect
us against those risks were representing
the were promoting instead the interest
of the regulated industry and so I've
you know litigated against all the you
look at all of these agencies you know
the ones I've litigate against FDA a FCC
I just won a case in the court of
appeals against FCC for lying to the
American public about the safety of cell
phone
radiation and now they've got to go back
and redo those rules and they're just
stonewalling it but if you look at all
the I've Su NIH F CDC EPA uh uh and uh
FCC uh FDA all of them the agencies that
even the agencies the intelligence
agency like the CIA the function of the
CIA now is to is to promote new Wars to
feed the war
machine I I had dinner about uh I don't
know two and a half months ago with Mike
Pompeo here in Las Vegas never met Mike
Pompeo before he was the head of the CIA
and he was also the Secretary of State
he's a highly educated person he went to
Harvard Law School Harvard undergraduate
he was uh you know he was a war fighter
combat veteran he his illustrious career
I never liked him because I saw him as
part of the you know the war machine but
he said to me during this
dinner um he said he said the one thing
that I didn't do when I was at CIA that
I'm going to regret for the rest of my
life is I didn't clean up that agency
and he said I had an opportunity to do
that and I did not do it and then he
turned to me and he said the entire
upper etan of that agency is made up of
people who do not believe in the
Democratic institutions of the United
States of America oh you have an agency
that you know is supposed to protect our
national security but it's it and my
uncle recognized this even back in
1960 when he had to fire the three top
people of the ageny Allan dullas Richard
Bissell and Charles Cabell for um for
minded to him about the Bay of Pigs that
got us into the Bay of Pigs and he took
public blame for it but he said
privately to his AIDS he said I want to
take the CIA and shatter it into a
thousand pieces and Scatter it to the
winds because he knew it had been
captured by the military industrial
complex three days before he came into
office President Eisenhower made a
speech that uh that is probably today in
retrospect the most important spee spee
that's ever been made in American
history he made it on my birthday I went
to my uncle's
inauguration he made it three days
before on my birthday January 17th
1961 and he warned in that speech and
this is the commander the grand
commander of and during World War II of
our whole effort and he warned the
American people of the emergence of a
military industrial complex that would
transform America from the exemplary
democracy that we were supposed to be
into an a military Imperium abroad and a
surveillance State a Security State
National Security State a Garrison
stayed at home and my uncle spent His
Thousand Days in the White House
fighting against that cartel and keeping
us out of War he never sent a combat
troop abroad to to die he kept us out of
WS he kept us out of in 61 he kept us
out of Berlin in ' 62 he kept us out of
Cuba in 61 and again during the missile
crisis in '
62 um and he kept us out of Vietnam his
Aid all of his AIDS including his his
most trusted advisers like General Max
Taylor and uh and uh ail Harman and uh
and Dean aeson and the others all said
you got to send 250,000 troops to
Vietnam or the government's going to
collapse and he said it's not our fight
it's their government you know we can
help them the way the French did with us
during the American Revolution but we
can't fight their War for
them and finally he sent 16,000 military
advisers mainly Green Berets there were
fewer he sent fewer troops to Vietnam
and he sent to Oxford Mississippi to put
one black man James Meredith into Old
Miss so and in October 22nd in 1962 he
learned that one of those green ra had
died and he asked wal rosow his Aid to
bring him a casualty list and Walt rosow
showed him the cas list that showed 75
Americans that died in
Vietnam and he said that's too many I'm
bringing them all home and that
afternoon he signed National Security
order 263 or ordering All American
military personnel out of
Vietnam by 1965 with the first thousand
coming to home in December of 63 so so
six weeks
later and 30 days after he signed that
order he was murdered and a week after
that Linda Johnson remanded that order
sent 250,000 troops in Vietnam which
everybody had been asking my uncle to
do Nixon then came in and sent 560,000
56,000 of our troops never came home
including my cousin George SK who died
in the teda Fest we killed million of
them my father ran against that war in
68 and uh was killed the night he on the
California primary it was clear that he
was going to go to the White House and
Martin Luther King who had become a
peace activist um died two months
earlier was shot two months
earlier and those traumas my uncle's
death my father's death Martin Luther
King's death the Vietnam War
itself 911 and Co
each one of those traumas pushed us a
little bit farther down that road into
what uh into the world that we own today
which is the world that President
Eisenhower warned us about where you
know our democracy is now hollowed out
it's a Kabuki theater of democracy we go
through the motions and we have these
institutions but none of us believe that
our voices are audible at all inside the
Bel and they aren't
and it's because those
agencies became captured by that that
cartel that uh uh that Eisenhower warned
us about so and then the FED of course
has been captured the Fed was started
for good reason to put elasticity and
liquidity into the
markets in order to bail us out of
financial to give to sound financial
institutions help them get through
financial crisis and and deflation but
it's now been captured by Wall
Street which uses this quantitative
easing flooding the the the the the our
country with easy money so that
everybody then uh invests in equity but
people buy business Etc and and
withdrawing it and all of that Equity
then collapses people go bankrupt and
Wall Street comes in the big Bankers
Black Rock stat re
bankard and scoop up all that equity and
all of wealth is being funneled
systematically upward to this new
oligarchy and Co was you know the end of
that Co during the covid
lockdowns we closed 3.3 million
businesses and um and without any
scientific citation without any due
process without any environmental impact
statement without any notice and comment
Ru making no public hearings just one
bureaucrat who just said shut down all
the business
and never gave us a scientific
rationale and during that 500 Days of
lockdown we shifted 4 trillion dollar
the biggest shift in wealth in in human
history from the American middle class
to this new oligarchy of
billionaires we created a billionaire a
day during the pandemic and we
impoverished the American public and all
of it is ultimately traced back to that
agency capture you know and particularly
the FED which is now you know it has
nothing to do with the interest of the
American
people it's all about printing money to
to um to enhance the wealth of this of
the of the group that control
it wow it's a lot of information a lot
of lot of sad stats there
um I've heard that ideally the the goal
is is that we'll own nothing that we as
people will be happy owning nothing
is this the ultimate goal of all of this
with black rock Vanguard buying all the
homes essentially putting us in a
position where we will have to be
dependent and we won't be autonomous
anymore yeah I mean what I always try to
do Danica is to not look into people's
heads and say this is why they're doing
it but what you know we can what I do
report is there the statements that
people made so black rock
is is the
ultimate uh let's say profiteer of all
of these bat almost all these bat poliy
Black Rock Vanguard and State Street are
the biggest corporations down on Earth
Black Rock has1 trillion dollar under
management the the state of
California the GDP is three about three
and a half trillion a year or three
trillion a year so black rock is three
times bigger than California the economy
it is the third largest economy in the
world after China and the United States
you know those three collectively own
89% of the s&p500 so they own American
Business they're now trying to buy all
the land they're buying the agricultural
land and they're snapping up the um the
housing um the particularly single
family homes black rock is not buying
single family homes itself but it owns
Black Stone which is and that's the
reason that
housing prices have now increased from
two uh the average price of a house two
years ago was
$215,000 today it's
$400,000 and the the interest rates have
gone from 3% to 7% so a kid who goes out
and buys a home today is going to pay
10% interest and nobody can afford it
and and you've all heard stories of
people who who are about to go into
escrow on a home who are about to uh put
down money or sign a contract and at the
last
minute somebody comes in with a cash
offer 20% greater than than the asking
price and they snap that home off the
mark and you say who is this person who
has all this cash and then you find out
that it's an LLC with an ambiguous
name and if you follow the the the
breadcrumbs that leads you to Black
Black Rock State treat and Vanguard and
um and they are you know that they're
they're we're on a trajectory now they
already own about 6% of the housing of
the single family homes in this country
I on this trajectory they'll own between
40 and 60% within six
years and we're going from an ownership
Society to a rental society and my you
know my kids cannot you know I have
seven kids I have eldest one is 39 and
he is in a home but all the younger ones
went to the best schools in our country
they have great jobs and none of them
has even a chance in their own mind of
ever buying a
home and none of their friends
still and you know that's a real problem
for our country and we've let down this
generation of kids um and I'll come back
to that in a second but to answer your
question the head of black rock is a guy
called Larry think and Larry think sits
on the board of the world economic Forum
which is you know sponsors every year
this what they call the billionaires
Boys Club this big con uh uh convocation
in
Davos where they all come together the
billionaires of the planet to arrange
what you know the what the world will
look like for the rest of humanity and
their their tagline for where they're
headed is called they call it the great
reset when CLA Schwab who's the head of
the world economic Forum was asked what
in to explain and a summarize in a
sentence what the great reset means he
said it means that you will own nothing
and yet you will be happy so uh they're
in charge of the first part which is
that we will own nothing and then we're
going to be in charge of the of the
second part which is figuring out why
you know how to be happy and you know
people aren't happy with this there
there was a very disturbing poll that
came out recently there was a poll in
2013 that asked American young people
people between 18 and 39 years
old whether they were proud of the
United States of America and 85% of them
said yes the same poll taken a month
ago uh the same group of people only 18%
they were proud said they were proud of
our country so the young people in this
country
country have completely lost their faith
and their pride in America and they and
it's because they have no hope for their
own future and it's our fault because we
have let them down you know we have
betrayed them and you know when I was a
kid the the prom the central Bedrock
promise of the American dream was that
if you worked hard if you play by the
rules that you can you can Finance the
home
you can raise a family you can take a
summer vacation you can put something
aside for your retirement and uh and on
one
job and there's nobody in this
generation that believes that that
promise applies to them you know there's
nobody and we have utterly betrayed this
generation of kids and they're growing
up hopeless and to me that's uh you know
that's what I want to change that
present when when we had after World War
II there was a 50-year period in this
country and that economists call uh the
the great Prosperity when the American
middle class became the greatest
economic engine in the history of
mankind and we owned half when I was a
boy my uncle was President we owned half
the wealth on the face of the Earth we
were the biggest exporter of goods we
were the moral Authority in the planet
everybody wanted what we had they wanted
our blue jeans our transistor radios our
RCA
patrollers American automobiles were the
gold standard car in the world and um
and a lot of that a lot of that was
because you know we had destroyed our
bombs and you know and Hitler's War had
destroyed the industrial base of of
Japan and Europe um and that we had we
still had an industrial base in this
country that we had ramped up you know
for the War Machine and now we're we're
beating into plow
shares but the big reason also that that
happened was we got every American into
a home in 19 in 1946 and 1947 we passed
the GI Bill and a whole bunch of other
legislation that made it really easy for
American middle class to buy a
home because they own home if you own a
home you care about your community you
care about you you know you go to the
PTA meetings you care about your schools
you care about the police the hospital
the
transportation you care about the
appearance of your home your
neighborhood you care about your
neighbors and um and but more
importantly you have an entree into
American capitalism because you have
equity which means you can borrow money
which means you can pursue your
entrepreneurial
impulse you can you can create a
business you can borrow you can take a
second mortgage and you can bet it on a
restaurant or a yoga studio or or retail
outlet and this you know this capacity
this access of an entire generation of
Americans to equity to
Capital allowed them to to to exploit
what Franklin Roosevelt called America's
industrial genius the entrepreneurial
Spirit of our country and actually act
on it when you turn us into a nation
from a nation of owners to a nation of
renters we go from being citizens to
being subjects because people can no
longer participate in capitalism Teddy
Thomas
Jefferson
American democracy will only survive if
we continue to have if the land is
controlled the land Bas is controlled by
tens of thousands of Y yman uh
individuals and families each with a St
in our our capitalist system and each
with with a stake in our political
system and today we're losing that you
know these three companies are now uh
owning everything and not only you know
we're we're now in a situation
where um the average income in this
country is now $5,000 less than the
Clause of basic human needs so um if you
are in that cohort which is more than
half of our of our our countrymen of
citizens um you end up even buying not
good food like you get Whole Foods but
you know the the grocery store food that
is loaded with chemicals where you have
to eat eight carrots today to have the
same nutritional value as as one garot
had 20 years
ago even living at a basic income food
transportation and housing you end up at
$55,000 in debt at the end of the year
how are Americans handling that they're
putting it on their credit card oh and
Visa Mastercard um Wells Fargo City Bank
Chase and
Morgan are charging them $22 2.2%
interest this commercial fisherman sent
me a screenshot of his credit card bill
about a week ago was 37%
interest if the Maia did that it would
be called lone sharking and they go to
jail but um you know these credit card
companies is business as usual and who
owns every one of those companies Black
Rock State Street and Vanguard during
that during the
pandemic we had we closed all these
businesses but we kept one business open
Amazon and we all got a a three-year
lesson on how to use Amazon Amazon
censored one of my books criticizing the
lockdown I'm suing them for it and so
they got to they got to criticize the
the the policy that was closing down all
their competitors and minting them
hundreds of billions of dollars and we
all learned how to use Amazon I didn't
know how to use Amazon prior to the
pandemic I you know and it's magical of
course you you find a picture of
something you want and you put send and
it's in your driveway the next day so
that's very very
seductive but we pay a price for that
convenience which is the local retailer
who is paying taxes in this neighborhood
is now gone 41% of blackowned businesses
will never
reopen and these were the guys who
employed your kid during the summer
vacation they had they're the guys with
the with the uh you know the plaque on
their wall from the local boy clout
troop of appreciation and the guys who
paid for my children's hockey jerseys
with their little league uniforms
they're gone so you spent a little more
at that
retailer but that money circulated in in
our community again and again and again
and enriched us all today they're gone
and Amazon doesn't pay local taxes and
guess what they don't pay federal taxes
last year they paid
zero and who's the biggest owner of
Amazon Black Rock State Street and
Vanguard well you see you know what that
they're they're doing it right front of
us they're strip mining the wealth and
the equity from the American public
they're destroying our capacity for
sovereignty for you know for
self-enrichment for fulfillment or
spiritual and and uh and economic
fulfillment and uh and you know they
they have too much power and they also
are the biggest contributors to the
political party I I'll tell you one
other thing that we commit we committed
$13 billion to uh to
Ukraine in March of last year and that
same month um and and by the way we've
then given them another 24 billion cents
and now President Biden's asking for
another 60 billion for a war that should
have never happen the Russians tried
repeatedly to settle it on terms that
were extraordinarily beneficial to us
and Ukraine oh and we made zinsky tear
up those agreements after he signed them
and the Russians were withdrawing these
are things that we don't hear from the
mainstream media because they're all
oned by Black Rock St
mangard but
that same month 113 billion we we um we
committed that same month we cut food
stamps to 30 million Americans from $283
a month to $23 a month try living try
feeding yourself on 23 bucks a
month we cut 15 million Americans from
the Medicare roles and the FED printed
300 billion extra dollars
unanticipated to bail out the Silicon
Valley Bank so when the Bankers need it
and when the war machine needs it it uh
we got the doors wide open but when
Americans are hurting when they're
starving when they're hungry when
they're sick there's nothing there for
them and Mitch Mado was asked that month
um in March of 2022 the same when we
gave all this money committed the first
$13 billion
trunch he was he was as you know
Republicans are supposed to be concerned
about the D said can we really afford
and he said don't worry about it it's
not really going to Ukraine it's going
to American Military contractors to
Black
to the Norther grond
raon the General Dynamics to lock and uh
and and
Boeing and who do you think owns every
one of those companies Black
Rock and why do we want to you know the
war is really about whether we can can
move NATO into Ukraine
why do we want to move NATO into 15
countries we promise we wouldn't we
already moved it into 14 we promis when
the Soviets when gorbachov dismantled
the Soviet Union and allowed us to
reunite Germany that we would not move
Nato one inch to the east so why is the
drive to do it well part of it is that
when those countries sign up for NATO
they have to conform their military
purchases to Nato prescribed armaments
which are all made by those companies so
they're they're giving those companies a
big New Market it's a guaranteed Market
that's worth billions for
them oh Tim Scott during the Republican
debate said when all the Republicans
were were saying about how they want to
yeah we're gonna do we're gonna we're
gonna give whatever Ukraine wants to win
this war we got to do that and then uh
and and the Democrats are saying the
same thing by the way but they said
there then we're going to go to China
and we're going to go fix them and we're
going to go to war war with Mexico and
one of the the MC's said from Fox said
well you know that's going to cost a lot
of money are Republicans supposed to be
concerned about the deficit and Tim
Scott said well don't worry because it's
not a gift to ukra it's a
loan oh raise your hand if you think
that loan is getting paid back right
it's not nobody thinks it is it's not it
why do they even say it well because
when you when you call it a loan it
gives you the ability to impose loan
conditions what are those conditions
well an extreme austerity program for
the Ukraine that makes sure if you're
poor in Ukraine you're going to stay
poor
forever but more importantly Ukraine is
forced to put all of its assets up to
sale on the international market to to
multinational corporations so it's it's
airports its ports it's you know toll
roads
whatever most importantly all of its
land it's agricultural land U my son
fought in Ukraine incident he fought
with a a Special Forces Unit in the K
offensive as machine gunner oh you know
I have great compassion for the people
of Ukraine but they're getting they're
getting rolled they're a proxy war and
you know and to serve geopolitical
Ambitions of of you know in a war
between the United States and
Russia but um Tim Scott said it's alone
well here's a big thing the the
agricultural land of Ukraine is the most
valuable asset in Europe arguably it is
the Bread Basket of Europe it's the
richest foreign land in the world and
there's been a thousand years of wars
fought over it there's now 450,000
Ukrainian kids who should never have
died but who have died to protect that
land to keep it in
Ukraine but the loan agreement says they
got to put it all up for sale it creates
something called a land market and
they've already sold 30% of it who
bought it
Monsanto Dupont and
cargo who owns every one of those
companies
BlackRock oh and then and then the big
costs of that
war are going to come after the peace
when we rebuild all of the the things
that we that we just destroyed
and we get to tell who gets the contract
to do that and that's already been
settled who do you think it is who got
the entire contract Black
Rock they're doing it right in front of
us and they don't care because they
don't care that we know about it why
because that system they have is
fixed they have a mechanism for making
sure that we never solve this problem
which is they keep us all at each
other's throats they keep the
Republicans and the Democrats hating
each other and blacks and whites and
immigrants
National and when the king and queen
look over the ballustrades of their
castle and they see all their subjects
fighting each other they go back to that
banquet hall and they pop champagne
quirks because they know nobody's coming
over the wall for them and that's how
they do it and what I've pledged to do
over the next 12
months and over the eight years of my
Administration is to stop all that
fighting and go over the wall and take
our country back from from the people
who
sto how feel like we're getting an
understanding why nobody wants to debate
you because there's a lot that's being
hidden and some of it's not even being
hidden anymore and your polls are on the
rise formula 1's the fastest growing
sport in this world it's and it's
because of this transparency I don't
know how big of fans you guys are of
drive to survive and various different
things like that but driver's social
media you're seeing more you're getting
to see what's really happening behind
the curtains and that's exactly what
you're doing with your campaign is
you're telling people what's really
happening and it's shocking and it's sad
and we all want to be autonomous human
beings with sovereignty where we can
grow and expand and own things
so what do you believe is the most
important top IC it is so hard to turn
the big ship of this country as a
president that one thing that you're
going to do that's going to start
turning the ship what's what's that's
going to be well I you know I think
generally it's about dismantling this
this corrupt merger of state and
corporate power but you and you know
each one of those each one of those
agencies has to be fix that's how you do
it you you unravel the corporate capture
and because I've litigated against them
all I have a unique knowledge about how
to do that when you litigate against an
agency you get a PhD and um and how to
in corporate capture and how to unravel
it I know the individuals in a lot of
these agencies who the center the hubs
of the corruption I know I understand
the
perverse incentives that are uh that are
part of the policies that uh that that
put corporate capture on
steroids um and I you know I I have a
deep understanding of of the agencies
and how they work and how to fix them I
I think my understanding of it is unique
because of my background and just in
litigating against them and seeing the
corruption
firsthand I wouldn't call myself
political I get sort of turned off by
the drama um the presentation of
information versus
execution what would you say to people
out there that have been turned off by
politics why why should we be engaged
well I understand why people are turned
off because like I said it's not really
it's a Kabuki theater and you know
you're
not I mean how did we end up in a place
where we have 3 what 80 million people
in this country and the two people that
you're given a choice to vote
for by the major political parties are
people that most Americans don't even
want to run you know um you know one of
them who has and I'm not saying you know
it a bad thing but I think it's obvious
to everybody became obvious to me
because I wanted to debate President
Biden but I don't think he's capable of
doing that I don't think he's capable
right now of having unscripted
encounters with voters and then you know
president Trump who has a very very
strong and um you know and loyal core
that doesn't represent the most of the
people in this
country um have uh you know has legal
problems and a lot a lot of other issues
so if you when you poll Americans it's
like 83% of them don't want this
choice and the um and so I I understand
why people are disillusioned with our
country but I think you know it it's not
time to give up it's time to try to do
what we can to take our country back
thank you thank you so much thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear hear more please click
on the Subscribe button